[Musique]
bonsoir on va parler d'une personne très
importante quelqu'un d'essentiel dans
votre vie savez-vous de qui allons nous
parler idées personnes eh bien on va
parler de vous pourquoi pas parce que
vous êtes la personne la plus importante
vous êtes pour vous la personne la plus
importante donc on va parler de vous et
j'aurais question parce que des fois
vous vous dites j'ai de la chance j'ai
la chance de quoi la chance d'avoir un
logement d'avoir à manger d'avoir la ctu
d'avoir la paix puisque finalement ses
70 ans que nous n'avons pas de guerre en
france
et puis surtout de vivre dans un des
pays les plus riches au monde a cette
chance dans cet environnement protégé
elle nous donne plein de choix de vie
plein d'opportunités plein de liberté
vous avez peut-être un doute de ça
puisque on entend des fois des gens dire
que finalement la france c'est pas top
top bien n'hésitez pas n'hésitez pas à
vous dire plus souvent et à regarder
plus souvent ce que vous avez et elle
comptait elle matérialisée et moins
souvent ce qui vous manque
n'hésitez pas parce qu'il suffit de
prendre un téléphone ou regard des
informations aussi à vous comparez dans
des endroits moins confortant donc dans
cet environnement confortable vous avez
envie de réussir votre vie et d'être
heureux pour cela vous allez la remplir
de plein de choses qui vous font du bien
tout d'abord des moments avec les amis
la famille vous allez chercher un métier
vous épanouir on vous l'avez peut-être
déjà vous allez aussi faire des
activités des loisirs en lien avec vos
coûts ce qui est important c'est que
vous sachiez que ce bonheur que vous
cherchez il ne dépend que de vous
maintenant que vous êtes autonome
je m'adresse principalement au jeu des
étudiants qui viennent de quitter leurs
parents et ça va être comme ça tout au
long de votre vie sauf que dans votre
vie dans 15 ans ou dans 50 ans puisque
vous partir à la retraite un peu plus
tard qu'aujourd'hui vous vous dites
vous n'avez sûrement pas envie de vous
dire je n'ai pas fait ceci ou cela ou je
n'ai pas découvert un tel endroit serait
dommage de regretter de ne pas avoir
fait des choses qui étaient possibles
quand elles se sont présentées
alors j'ai un conseil saisissez les
opportunités quand elles se présentent
le fait-on souvent mais pas toujours
pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce que pour
la plupart d'entre nous avons la chance
comme je l'aï dit dans cet environnement
confortable de vivre heureux dans le
confort c'est quoi le confort c'est pas
celui de votre chambre d'étudiante au
sens des mètres carrés que vous avez non
c'est le confort d'être près de ses amis
d'être près de ses parents ont peut-être
encore pour certains d'habiter chez eux
d'avoir votre cercle de personnes avec
qui vous faites beaucoup d'activités
beaucoup de bons moments et tout ça
c'est confortable c'est rassurant
ça vous demande peu d'efforts trois
clics 3 sms et ça y est votre soirée est
organisée
c'est aussi peu d'imprévu finalement
parce que dans ce cercle lavours fait
souvent des activités que vous
connaissez déjà et le plus d'importance
et souvent c'est du bonheur et pourquoi
changer les choses qui sont agréables
mais ça a des inconvénients qu'on voit
pas toujours où qu'ils finissent un jour
par arriver on peut citer par exemple la
routine risque dans nuit parce que
finalement c'est sympa de voir toujours
les mêmes personnes mais peut-être moins
de choses à se raconter que quand on en
découvre de nouvelles quand on découvre
de nouvelles activités
donc ces inconvénients ils peuvent
prendre du poids dans la vie ils peuvent
d'ailleurs à même un peu abîmée votre
bonheur
si l'ennui prend trop de place donc pour
cela
si vous avez envie de nouveauté de
découvrir de nouvelles personnes d'aller
faire des nouvelles activités
eh bien il faut sortir de son confort
cette zone de confort qui vous offrent
beaucoup de bonheur vous pouvez en
sortir tout en gardant autant de bonheur
alors en sortant de votre zone de
confort vous allez vivre des choses
probablement très enrichissante
en complément de celles que vous avez
dans votre zone de confort et
la première chose qui peut vous freinez
à le faire c'est de vous dire finalement
c'est quand même pas toc toc de sortir
de sa zone de confort parce que vous
partez dès fois à l'inconnu est cet
inconnu il fait peur
par principe on n'aime pas un inconnu
vous allez dans certains cas peut-être
voir retrouver tout seul en tout cas si
vous êtes loin de chez vous de voir vous
débrouiller tout seul vraiment tout seul
et ça aussi c'est moins confortable que
quand en trois clics ou de coups de
téléphone les parents les amis vous aide
et solidarité est là et elle fait les
trois quarts du travail et puis ceux
justement qui apporte ce bonheur
aujourd'hui et pinces ils sont loin de
vous il y aura un jour le téléphone
toujours les réseaux sociaux mais c'est
pas pareil que de les voir bah ils vont
vous manqué finalement vous n'avez pas
forcément envie de sortir du confort
pour que les gens vont donc heureusement
qu'il ya beaucoup de bénéfices à sortir
du confort 20 dans les bénéfices
le premier c'est que vous allez faire
nouvelles rencontres nouvelles activités
ici je les appelais la nouvelle tribu et
sert en fait ces nouvelles personnes
vont créer une deuxième tribut après
celle que qui était celle de votre
enfance ou de votre confort initial et
puis puisque vous partez à l'imprévu
vous allez forcément avoir des imprévus
il va falloir les régler tout seul vous
allez développer de l'autonomie de la
capacité d'adaptation et vous allez
réussir à vous adapter et en réussir
vous adaptez vous allez développer en
plus de l'autonomie qui va s'agrandir de
la capacité d'adaptation renforcer et
beaucoup de confiance en vous et cette
confiance elle va être important elle
sera important quand vous reviendrez
votre votre confort sera importante pour
le reste de votre vie donc soyez sûr que
ses bénéfices
ils peuvent être très importants et très
utiles à votre personnalité et puis bien
sûr ceux qui vous ont manqué si vous
voulez revoyez moins souvent ou qu'ils
viennent vous voir là vous êtes parti
mais les moments de joie seront sûrement
immense
en tout cas peut-être plus fort que si
vous n'avez pas vu ces mêmes personnes
la veille
donc il ya le bénéfice d'avoir des
grands moments de joie avec des gens
qu'on aime et qu'on a laissé pendant un
certain temps un petit peu loin de vous
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça ben
comment et quand le faire et ou alors
pour vous qui êtes jeunes étudiants je
sais qu'il y en a un certain nombre qui
ont des projets déjà de partir de
s'éloigner un peu avec des études
c'est déjà un vrai départ sur une sort
de sa zone de confort je le reconnais
même si une partie de vous allez quand
même bien structuré bien organisé
puisque vous faites des études dans un
endroit qui est relativement connu des
étudiants vous ont probablement précédé
donc l'inconnu est un petit peu moins
fort que si vous partiez dans d'autres
endroits mais c'est déjà une vraie
première étape est en tout cas sachez
que vous êtes en sortant d'école mais
pas tout de suite hein pas cette année
attendait quand même vos diplômes je ne
souhaiterais pas avoir de problèmes avec
vos parents sortez de votre zone de
confort après parce que c'est le
meilleur moment vous n'avez pas encore
pour la plupart des attaches familiales
ni trop de contraintes professionnelles
donc c'est un moment idéal diplôme en
poche
évidemment alors ce paysage pas si pour
certains il parle
si vous êtes allés loin peut-être moi je
suis sorti de ma zone de confort je vous
parle est un tout petit peu de mon vécu
ce que ça va plus ma portée et qu'elles
ont été aussi les difficultés où je suis
parti en bolivie la bolivie c'est un
pays deux fois grand comme la france 10
millions d'habitants donc des grandes
contrées et peu peuplée avec un revenu
par habitant de 4000 $ en france il est
de 40 mille donc ça vous donne une idée
de niveau de richesse des habitants on a
toutes les attitudes tous les climats
ces deux mille kilomètres en dessous de
l'équateur
vous avez la jungle tropicale au niveau
amazonien et puis vous avez le plateau
des andes à 3800 mètres là où il ya la
capitale la paz capitale la plus haute
du monde
et puis vous avez aussi des volcans qui
ont neigé toute l'année fraude les 6500
mètres donc un très beau pays
ce que vous voyez là c'est le plus grand
désert de sel du monde il sera peut-être
demain la plus grande richesse de la
bolivie
ce qu'il est plein de lithium et c'est
un produit qui fait beaucoup parler de
lui en ce moment
sauf que quand je suis parti là-bas à 24
ans donc c'est l'époque il y avait
encore le service militaire qui pouvait
se faire à l'étranger
j'ai reçu un papier et ses marques et
vous partir en bolivie à l'ambassade de
france à la paz - pas beaucoup
d'informations il n'y avait pas internet
par les réseaux évidemment et
l'encyclopédie universalis on avait
plein et bibliothèques remplies de
livres qui pouvait nous apporter des
choses sauf que quand même à ce moment
là vous avez un petit moment de solitude
vous avez peur est bien fait parce que
finalement
papa maman les amis l'environnement les
copains tout ça je vais partir en dix
mille kilomètres de chez moi
ai-je bien fait on va le voir en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je me
posais beaucoup de questions tout
simplement quelques travail j'allais
faire où j'allais dormir quels amis
quelle activité
il allait falloir s'adapter on arrive en
bas me suis débrouillé seul comme on l'a
vu mais pas si seul que ça puisque très
vite effectivement on rencontre des gens
on va vers les gens
on va vers des nouvelles personnes il ya
aussi des gens qui veulent vous aider et
on rencontre suffisamment de gens pour
se recréer une petite tribu qui
s'élargira un prêt qui vous oblige
d'ailleurs à aller vers eux sinon vous
restez seul effectivement des gens qui
peuvent être des français qui eux aussi
sont partis et qui peuvent être bien sûr
des boliviens
je me suis adapté ça a été dur au début
mais ça m'a enrichi puisque une
expérience dur qu'on passe c'est de la
confiance comme je vous disais pour
d'autres expériences dur qui peut vous
arriver dans la vie après trois ans
j'avais deux nouveaux amis des amis que
j'ai toujours là bas j'ai fait des
nouvelles activités comme l'alpinisme
toujours pas pratiqué en france qui
s'appelle landini ce malade n'a permis
de monter sûr c'est au sommet que je
vous ai décrit et qui m'a apporté voilà
beaucoup de bonheur j'ai voyagé aux
quatre coins du pays
rencontré beaucoup de gens je vais vous
parler un peu justement de au delà des
lieux magiques que j'ai rencontrés qui
n'existe pas en france évidemment
puisque nous sommes dans des contrées
très différentes et des climats très
différents je vais vous parler un petit
peu de quelques aspects qui ont changé
un petit peu ma vision du monde où la
manière de voix qui sont des aspects
complémentaires aussi et qu'on garde
aussi pour la vie un des premiers
aspects c'est que j'ai eu la chance de
travailler avec un orphelinat donc je
disais qu'on est dans un pays pauvre et
que du coup dans ce pays pauvre les
orphelinats souvent les enfants sont en
très bas âge à peine nés sont déposés
sur le seuil de la porte
j'ai compris que le monde pouvait être
dur et cruel eux ils sont posés devant
la porte moi j'ai eu la chance de naître
en france dans une famille qui m'a tout
donné
voyez un petit peu d'émotion encore
avoir ce souvenir parce qu'effectivement
toutes ces expériences que j'ai vécues
et que vous aussi vous pouvez que vous
vivrez et que vous vivez déjà dans votre
confort aussi c'est finalement des
nouveaux souvenirs des moments forts et
vous savez peut-être que les émotions
vous pouvez vivre créer de souvenirs
c'est très important parce que
finalement s'il ya bien des choses on se
rappelle je pense à la fin de service et
de tous ses souvenirs
le reste est probablement moins
important de savoir ce qu'on a pu gagner
ou avoir un moment dans sa vie
j'ai compris également en travaillant à
l'ambassade de france où j'avais en
charge le développement de petits
projets un peu à titre humanitaire que
la france finance et pour les
populations les plus pauvres de bolivie
j'ai été en contact de populations
locales des villages où il n'y avait ni
eau ni électricité
des gens très simple qui vivait dans
l'open air et de petites parcelles
officiellement ces gens étaient heureux
parce qu'il vivait en lien avec la
nature libre et avec des choses simples
et avec un esprit communautaire très
fort parce qu'il a effectivement besoin
de s'entraîner quand les coups étaient
dures et cet esprit communautaire c'est
des valeurs qui m'ont beaucoup
rapprochés de la nature des choses
simples cherche pas aujourd'hui acquérir
et acquérir et acquérir et la nature
m'apporte beaucoup et puis l'esprit
solidarité et l'esprit de groupe de
communauté je l'appris de ces gens là
qui est finalement vu d'un premier abord
ne verra rien et finalement il avait
peut-être les choses les plus
importantes
ce que j'ai appris aussi si c'est pas
plus qu'à prendre puisque j'ai fait des
belles rencontres
vous parlez des amis mais j'ai aussi
trouvé ma femme ici présentes et donc
pour moi ça a été aussi l'occasion de
construire une famille donc c'est des
opportunités qui se sont présentées et
qui font qu'aujourd'hui voilà elles sont
toujours solides et puis côté
professionnel parce que je partais pour
travailler j'ai eu l'occasion
parce qu'on à l'étranger de fond des
responsabilités bien plus importante et
plus rapidement quand on le fait en
france dans le cadre et 40 personnes
c'était mon premier post c'était mon
premier job
après quelques mois quand même sur un
chantier de reforestation forêts
tropicales dans un parc national
et cette expérience de management m'a
amené à apprécier ce métier qui est
fortement basée sur les relations
humaines et du coup j'ai continué et je
le fais toujours et je vous parlais de
d'épanouissement dans le travail et
c'est très important et aujourd'hui je
suis très heureux de continuer à être
manager alors
après vous a parlé un petit peu de moi
vous pourriez faire quoi si demain vous
décidez de vous poser la question de
partir vous pourriez aller travailler
dans une organisation non
gouvernementale pour une cause qui vous
tient à coeur on en a vu plusieurs
aujourd'hui il ya plein de choses à
faire
ça peut être pas très loin et ça peut
être beaucoup plus loin vous de choisir
vous pourriez aller enlever volontaire
international en entreprise donc c'est
somme toute classique ce que vous auriez
fait en france à aller chercher un job
vous allez faire votre premier job à
l'étranger dans une entreprise qui a
besoin de jeunes comme vous même sans
expérience pour des durées de 6 à 24
mois et il ya plein de boîtes françaises
qui ne demande qu'à se développer à
l'international et il y en a déjà
cherché les vous en trouverez et puis
dernier point vous avez peut-être déjà
fait vous pensez faire un jour après vos
études faire un bon break et de faire un
tour du monde ou un bout d'os tour du
monde tellement le monde est grand et
puis vous irez à la rencontre des
cultures et des peuples que vous aurez
décidé de de d'explorer dans un bout du
mans donc des choses il y en a plein par
contre le risque c'est le frein le frein
d'aller dans une entreprise à l'étranger
alors qu'on n'a jamais travaillé que je
ne sais rien faire par exemple le frein
dire c'est pas pour moi où je suis pas
assez autonomes j'ai pas encore voyager
assez bon on peut sans créer plein des
freins on s'en crée tous les jours on a
l'impression que ce métier là et pas
pour nous on n'est pas fait pour 6%
donc c'est vraiment important de passes
22 fera donc fait sauter les freins et
regarder les choses dans l'angle de la
solution trouver des solutions on va
maintenant passer au vote interactif
donc je vous propose de reprendre votre
mobile et suite à cette première partie
la plus longue
je vais vous poser donc vous voulez bien
taper le code qui est en bas je vais le
l'éclairer voilà vous avez le 96 673 sur
la page que vous avez dû télécharger
donc est-ce que vous avez le temps de
taper son code
une petite touche ok et vous allez on va
lancer le premier test encore 3,4
secondes
allez c'est parti pour la première
question
on lance la régie c'est parti donc vous
avez trente secondes pour répondre à ce
que vous auriez envie de faire et qui
rendra aux dix plus enrichissantes
êtes vous plutôt à continuer à vous
épanouir dans votre sphère sociale
actuelle ce qui peut être une très bonne
chose pour
où êtes vous plutôt prêts à découvrir le
monde depuis votre tablette ou tout
simplement partir pour un pays qui vous
attire et rencontrer ses habitants
il n'y a que des bonnes réponses ce
n'est pas un quiz
c'est plutôt un sondage donc répondait
ce qui vous vient le plus naturellement
et nous aurons la vision de la salle
tout simplement
alors il reste ça y est on arrive au
bout donc pour ceux qui ont répondu je
ne sais pas si je vois le nombre de
réponses 59 réponse vous êtes en grande
partie à allait partir dans un pays qui
vous attire donc je ne sais pas si c'est
moi qui vous ai convaincus vous l'étiez
déjà mais en tout cas on est en phase
vous avez des choses enrichissante a
fait deuxième question on enchaîne donc
vous allez avoir la deuxième question
qui apparaît elle est plus sûr le
bonheur est ce que pour vous donc c'est
parti vous pouvez répondre vous comptez
plutôt miser sur le fait de devenir
célèbre pour être heureux sur le fait de
privilégier la qualité des relations
humaines ou tout simplement travailler
pour devenir riche et vous offrir ce qui
vous plaît vous reste quinze secondes
ayant une fois de plus toutes les
réponses sont bonnes donc c'était le
petit séquence digital cette
intervention nous y arrivons au bout il
n'y aura pas d'autres questions
les résultats vont s'afficher donc vous
mettez les relations humaines comme
quelque chose de fondamental dans votre
quotidien
eh bien écoutez vous êtes relativement
emphase que je vais passer la conclusion
la conclusion c'est qu'une étude la
grande université d'harvard qui a duré
plus de 70 ans et qui continue sur une
population plus de 700 personnes ils les
ont étudiées pendant 70 ans tous les ans
tout le temps tout le monde hommes
femmes riches pauvres et une seule
conclusion est arrivé à la fin c'est
alors qu'on va avancer que il faut miser
sur la qualité des relations
donc exit célébrité et la richesse si
vous voulez vivre plus heureux et
surtout plus longtemps parce que vous
serez en meilleure santé
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]